le quartier de shia donne l'impression
d'avoir été frappé par une catastrophe
naturelle mais sa destruction quasi
totale est le fruit de l'homme de la
guerre
ici se sont déroulés les combats les
plus intenses pendant l'opération
israélienne bordure protectrice l'été
dernier shia a des airs de ville fantôme
mais en y regardant de plus près ce
n'est pas tout à fait le cas ici et là
les habitants de shia sont revenus
occuper les décombres comme vous le
voyez on ne fait rien de toute la
journée on attend la pitié de dieu pour
qu'il nous fournisse des bienfaiteurs
pour reconstruire nos maisons
ali passe ses journées entières sur ce
qui reste de la maison où il a vu
grandir ses quatre fils avec sa femme
nous avons acheté ce bout de terrain il
ya 45 ans et pendant 45 ans nous avons
construit cette maison elle a été
détruite en une seule journée
on a que ce bout de terrain là cette
maison c'est tout ce qu'on avait à là
bas le cas des backrooms n'a rien
d'exceptionnel à gaza au moins cent
mille personnes ont fui leurs maisons
pendant la guerre qui a duré sept
semaines environ dix mille d'entre eux
habitent toujours dans les écoles de
l'unrwa l'office de secours des nations
unies pour les réfugiés palestiniens
pourtant après le cecil plus le 26 août
dernier la communauté internationale
avait promis plus de 5 milliards de
dollars pour reconstruire toutes ces
vies brisées
mais depuis la conférence du caire les
promesses tardent à se matérialiser la
reconstruction prennent
pour l'instant on a on a un gap de 545
millions de dollars
pour tout ce qui est de loyer
reconstruction réparation des dommages
qu'ils soient mineurs ou majeurs se sont
bien 545 millions de dollars américains
sur les 720 millions prévus au programme
dead un trou béant qui a forcé le droit
à suspendre temporairement son programme
à la fin février d'un moment ça pas été
suivie d'effet donc on est obligé
d'annoncer la suspension des paiements
pour la réparation et la de loyer alors
bien sûr ça a eu un impact ici pour les
gens une trentaine d'organismes dead ont
sonné l'alarmé dans une déclaration
commune sans précédent nous ne devons
pas abandonner gaza ont-ils dit montrant
du doigt israël en tant que puissance
occupante est la principale responsable
et doit se conformer à ses obligations
en vertu du droit international en
particulier elle doit lever totalement
le blocus
la vision politique à roye mana travail
pour oxfam
l'un des organismes signataires de la
lettre comme le blocus est toujours là
elle et il ya beaucoup de limitations et
de restrictions sur les matériaux
nécessaires pour la reconstruction de
gaza
pas seulement la reconstruction des
maisons on parle aussi la route
reconstruction des infrastructures
après trois guerres successives à gaza
oxfam va encore plus loin dans
l'évaluation des besoins d'une
population dont plus de 80% dépend
maintenant d'une forme ou d'une autre
l'aide alimentaire à ce rythme là et
avec la continuation de blocus ça peut
prendre son sens en pour gaza d'être
reconstruit
depuis la prise de contrôle de gaza par
le hamas dont la branche armée
considérée comme un groupe terroriste
par israël les états unis et le canada
israël a imposé un blocus
c'était il ya plus de sept ans car une
shalom et depuis le seul point de
passage des marchandises vers gaza les
matériaux de construction en prie si
sous haute surveillance
c'est l'autorité palestinienne à
ramallah qui approuvent les projets de
construction et non le hamas israël doit
aussi donner son accord
ce qu'il fait au compte-gouttes de peur
que le hamas ne détourne les matériaux
pour reconstruire ces tunnels détruit
pendant la guerre que le ciment entre ou
pas à gaza
slimane chamali n'a pas les moyens de
rebâtir sa maison crois que les
querelles politiques entre le hamas et
l'autorité palestinienne sont
responsables que le logo made tous les
gouvernements sont en train de faire la
guerre pour décider qui va prendre
l'argent de la reconstruction
celui-là 10 et mois l'autre dit c'est
moi et nous on se retrouve au milieu du
compresseur pour de pouvoir la
reconstruire un entrepreneur affaires de
démolir sa maison pour de bon en échange
des matériaux
à gaza on récupère chaque bout de métal
chaque bloc de béton tout ce qui pourra
servir à rebâtir slimane a perdu des
membres de sa famille pendant la guerre
dont deux hommes qui se battaient dans
les rangs du jihad islamique
ce qui reste de la famille vingt-trois
personnes vivent entassés dans un abri
temporaire à l'ombre des ruines un chien
errant ne subit pas ce qu'on subit et on
endure tout ça nos enfants sont morts
nos maisons détruites
on a perdu notre argent on a tout perdu
et on n'a plus qu'à dire merci à dieu
pour tous chaque jour à bout soubira
tisse patiemment les décombres de sa
maison
du matin jusqu'au soir il n'y reste plus
grand chose qui vaille
mais il espère retrouver les bijoux de
sa femme pour la faire sourire un peu
c'est la deuxième fois en six ans que la
famille voit sa vie s'effondrer lors de
la guerre de 2009 elle avait perdu un
fils ibrahim
en plus de la maison cette fois à bout
soubie qui a quelque chose d'un poète se
croit chanceux
attendre pour la reconstruction
c'est comme planter une aiguille dans le
bras de quelqu'un et le vide et
lentement très lentement de son sang il
espère qu'il survivra à magrie qu'il 5
c'est comme ça qu'on sent dans la tente
de la reconstruction
la dernière fois on a moins senti la
peine d'avoir perdu la maison à cause du
bruit c'est ici qu'ibrahim et enterré
alors pas question d'aller vivre
ailleurs
même si tout autour le rappelle la
guerre abou soubie prend des médicaments
pour ses nerfs depuis la guerre les il
n'hésite pas à fanfaronner pour faire
venir les enfants dont le petit
qu'ibrahim le cadet qui a remplacé le
faire qu'il n'a jamais connu il ya tant
de choses que je voudrais offrir à mes
enfants
la sécurité l'indépendance et
l'affection surtout je voudrais faire
disparaître la peur dans leur jus
j'essaye de toutes les façons mais
malheureusement je vois toujours la peur
dans leurs jours
pour eux comme pour bien des gazaouis
malgré le cessez-le-feu
la guerre n'est pas finie